I hate chick music by the way kinda say
that girls always sing songs and they
think that it's empowering and it just
makes you sound [ __ ] stupid okay this
is something about it like from the very
beginning like you remember hit me with
your best shot why are you crying you
get I'm just you said hitch okay my bad
I just I was listening to the words you
said let me hit you that hard you know
those are these dumb songs you know
don't you wish your girlfriend was hot
like me yeah I do what are you asking me
they're my girls were here for such some
rude action you with your old tired
girlfriend she come over finance don't
you wish your girlfriend was hot like me
you gotta be like this know what why
would I want all that fine ass not when
I got all this right here [ __ ] that's
that's [ __ ] up you know saying Beyonce
- we gotta set her on fire just set on
fire now - all her songs are just like
women just empowering Bobby on say hey
[ __ ] can you pay my bills then she gets
specific pay my telephone here now you
paying this bitch's bills then she think
you cheating on her so she like say my
name say my name when no one is around
you Beyonce Beyonce yeah what the [ __ ]
is that even mean I don't get it you try
to hit it I don't think you ready for
this jelly I don't think you ready for
this yeah um I'm ready for the jelly I'm
paying your bills
remember that sharing her from the bills
bit
that's the acquit Bills equal jelly it's
a real simple ass equation
you got me looking so crazy right now I
was laying in the hey Marco
you know my old leather yo she get on a
whim an independent opinion bill was not
you independent this [ __ ] is [ __ ]
bananas okay
I'm paying her bills
now she famous I live in her house now
she bought me a car and clothes now she
think I'm cheating on her to the left to
the left everything you own in a box to
the left you must know Annie let me tell
you why that's the stupidest one ever
ladies if all your man stuff can fit in
a box he ain't [ __ ] anyway do you see
how stupid that is like she you know
she's talking about how she bought him a
car and all this [ __ ] he's replaceable
that won't [ __ ] up replaceable is [ __ ]
she's not talking about jay-z attention
right now jay-z's box is full of [ __ ]
you know Sam Sam you got deeds and [ __ ]
in there diamonds and [ __ ] I got my box
[ __ ] pie so now I'm in this taxi cab on
the way to my mama's house with this box
in my lap
you call her up come on you know I love
you why are you doing this to me well if
you like it is you to put a ring on it
kill her